[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MULHOLLAND: My
name is Ryan Mulholland,
and I have the
privilege of serving
on the professional
services team that
is dedicated to ensuring
the success of our state
and local government
customers like New York City.
I've been engaged with
New York City Cyber
Command since December of
2017, and in that time,
I've had the absolute privilege
of working with a dedicated
team of New Yorkers that are
really focused on providing
the very best in cybersecurity
for New York and her residents.
In that time, I've watched
as they built a new approach
to cybersecurity and
one which I believe
will be the future of
the way we all look
to cybersecurity in the future.
And it's that dedicated
team and their efforts
here today that we get to
talk about for the first time.
So it is my pleasure to
introduce to you Colin Ahern
today-- pardon me, Colin Ahern.
He is the Deputy Chief
Information Officer
leading security sciences for
New York City Cyber Command.
Prior to joining the
cybersecurity effort
in New York City, Colin--
pardon me, Colin
served for seven years
as an officer in the
United States Army
where he served two tours in
Afghanistan and as commander
of a cyberspace
operations company.
After serving in the army, Colin
worked in the financial sector
focused on security engineering
and cyber threat intelligence.
In addition to degrees
from Tulane and NYU,
Colin is a certified information
security services professional
and a Google certified
professional data engineer.
Along with his
wife and daughter,
Collin lives in the
bustling burrow of Brooklyn.
Do me a favor, please welcome
Colin Ahern to the stage,
Deputy CISO, for New
York City Cyber Command.
[APPLAUSE]
COLIN AHERN: Thanks, Ryan.
So behind a simple idea
is complex engineering.
And when we started this
journey about 18 months ago,
our boss Jeff Brown, the chief
information security officer
of the city of New
York, threw down
the gauntlet and
that was to construct
a completely separate
responder environment that
was purpose built to
detect and respond to cyber
threats against city systems.
And we call that
system Juggernaut.
And behind a cool
demo is a big team.
What you see here is a
product of multiple teams
all working together
at New York City Cyber
Command throughout the
government of the city of New
York and throughout many of our
vendor partners like Google.
We think our approach is
instructive for those seeking
to enhance the way that
they manage cybersecurity
relevant data, approach
technology systems that
are large and complex,
and that they want
to be resilient and efficient.
And this is just one small part
of what we do in New York City
Cyber Command that we
also affectionately refer
to as NYC3, so if I
drop that little acronym
during this demo,
that's what it is.
And we-- this is a joint
effort with Google.
If you saw it just
outside at the booth,
we have a demo in the
public sector area,
so this is a joint effort.
And we wanted to solve this
problem at New York scale
or Google scale if you like.
And we wanted to call
this Juggernaut because we
know there's going to be
roadblocks along the way,
we know this is a
long journey, but we
know that we have the resources
to overcome those hurdles.
We also like that juggernaut--
if you didn't know this--
is British for a
large heavy truck,
and we think of our pipeline
as a highway of sorts.
So that's relevant.
So this is what we're
going to cover today,
a little bit about-- excuse me--
New York City Cyber
Command and what we do.
I'll talk in depth
about the data
pipeline, some of
the principles,
some of the key facts.
I'll do a demo.
I'll talk about
some key decisions
we made like zero touch,
infrastructure as code,
zero trust, BeyondCorp model
for context aware access.
And I also talk
about what we believe
to be the future of this space,
machine learning and advance
automation.
And you see a pretty
interesting fact, 8.6 million.
That is the population just
within the five boroughs so not
including the larger
New York Metro
area, which is about 20
million, or even the Northeast
megalopolis, which is
many more millions still.
And along with this
large metropolis
is a large and complex
IT infrastructure.
We have 3/16 public
IP addresses.
That's about $194,000.
We have hundreds and hundreds
of web applications ranging
from an application
residence can
use to see where their street is
going to be plowed to NYC.gov,
one of the 500 most visited
websites in the United States.
So a very big complex
infrastructure that we defend.
So New York City
Cyber Command, NYC3--
Doing Right by New Yorkers.
Number 1, we're a
new government agency
charged with defending New
York City and the city of New
York from cyber threats
and providing tools
so that residents,
visitors, and businesses can
lead safer lives online.
We have a dedicated team of
cybersecurity and technology
professionals that
monitor city systems
24/7, 365 in collaboration
with other city
agencies such as
Department of Information
Technology and
telecommunications
and other stakeholders
to ensure our cities
are safe and resilient
from cyber threats.
And number 3, we believe
that cybersecurity
is a public safety issue.
On behalf of city government
and this administration,
we lead the NYC
secure initiative,
which is a policy position
that says cybersecurity
is not only a public
safety issue but one
in which your government
owes you something.
It owes you actual
tools that you can use
to lead safer digital lives.
We have three tactics
under this policy.
Number 1 is an enterprise
grade mobile threat detection
app called the NYC Secure App
available on the iOS in Android
app stores.
You can just-- or
Google NYC secure app.
And we believe that
security and privacy are not
mutually exclusive.
Our mobile threat
detection app does
all of its work on
the mobile phone.
It doesn't send anything
outside of the phone.
It collects an OPII.
It doesn't even have the rights
to PII on your mobile device.
Two, we partnered with
a nonprofit organization
called Quad 9, which offers
free privacy respecting
recursive DNS filtering,
and we're rolling that out
to all free public
Wi-Fi networks
by the end of this year.
That's because we believe that
residents who use our Wi-Fi
should not be victimized
as they do so.
And number 3, those of you that
saw in the Wall Street Journal
last Thursday, our agency
and my boss Jeff Brown
partnered with the Manhattan DA,
Cy Vance, and the commissioner
of the New York City Police
Department, James O'Neill,
on cyber critical services
and infrastructure.
It is a local cybersecurity
critical infrastructure
focused organization
designed to break down
barriers between
organizations across verticals
and be selfless and ruthless
about defending the city of New
York against cyber threats.
So very briefly, that's
the executive order
that created us in July of
2017, executive order 28
signed by Bill de Blasio.
And broadly speaking, we wanted
to undertake a very substantial
problem in a new way.
And we have three
goals at a high level.
One is build a secure
cloud-based security log
aggregation platform
for city systems, Two,
enable via this platform
alerting visualization
and analytics for cybersecurity
professionals, both analytics
that we had with existing
vendor partner relationships,
capabilities that we might
acquire in the future,
and some capabilities
that we develop in-house.
And three-- and maybe
most philosophically--
we want to scale non linearly
with two kinds of demands
or two kinds of
issues that we face.
Number 1, demand on city
services that is delivered by,
with, and through a technology
system grows every single day.
In addition to 3/16
public IP addresses,
we have over 400,000 workstation
servers and mobile devices
that are city owned.
We have another half a million
or so connected devices ranging
from water meters
to the GPS devices
on the snowplows that enable
the app to tell you when
it's going to plow your street.
So this is a really, really,
really big and complicated
infrastructure.
And each one of those devices
in some way large or small
expands the threat surface.
And for those of you that saw
Mike Aiello's talk yesterday,
we want to reduce
that threat surface
to a meaningfully small area
that we as defenders can
interact with.
And additionally, the threats
against any one of those points
increases every single day.
Five years ago for
you to take advantage
of the most advanced
hacking tools allegedly made
available by the
National Security
Agency and other governments
around the world,
you would have to work
for those agencies.
If those of you that remember
the eternal blue [INAUDIBLE]
these are leveraging alleged
NSA type capabilities,
and you could today right
now pull out your laptop
and go to GitHub and have
the power of the NSA.
So that is a fundamentally
categorically different world
than even three
or five years ago,
and we need to be able
to respond to that there.
And we think that our
data pipeline does that.
To do that, we have a
number of core beliefs.
One is security.
The ability to do comprehensive
retrospective search
on our security telemetry
in a separate environment
fundamentally changes
the strategic dynamic
between us and our adversaries.
It enables detection
based on a variety
of sources with a variety
of partners in a secure way.
It can guide detection
and response efforts.
It can lead to faster
remediation and faster
detection and over time
allow us to leverage
a key asset, our data, in
order to become predictive,
and we'll talk about where
we think that's the case.
Additionally, we want our
confidence in the team,
confidence in the tools,
and confidence in the plan.
So we're-- obviously I spoke
about the incredible team we
have in New York
City Cyber Command.
I'm going to talk about just
one of the tools we have
and going forward the future,
zero trust networking, our plan
for fundamentally changing
the battlespace with regards
to cyber threats.
Two, flexibility.
Cyber is a team sport.
We need a security product
agnostic environment
that can allow multiple tools
to operate either concurrently
or in parallel.
We want to be able to
test, add new capabilities,
remove them rapidly.
We want to be data centric,
not product centric.
And broadly speaking we
want to move from a request
and response
framework to a publish
and subscribe framework.
And that's one that enables
the future of things
like machine learning,
things like automation.
Additionally, we need to build
federation and multi-tenancy
from the ground up.
We need to leverage metadata.
We need to apply this metadata
so that we can be fast.
This is a problem that has
to be done at machine speed,
not one at people speed.
Two, data centric.
What is data centric mean?
At some level, it's
about decision advantage.
We want to provide our network
operators and defenders
with decision advantage
over their adversary
because we want our defenders
and network operators
to be able to know and do more
faster than the adversary.
And you can't hire your
way out of that problem.
Obviously it starts
with a fantastic team,
but that's not where it ends.
It is about having the right
data to the right analyst
or analytical process
at the right time
with the right context.
You need context not
to negatively impact
business operations,
and you can't do that
without data that is trusted,
reliable, and verifiable.
So to restate that problem in
a slightly different way, each
and every day, we're asking
IT professionals and security
teams to make decisions.
Whether to take
an asset offline,
whether to remove access
to a system from some user,
they are making a trade.
They are reducing some
risk, which might be present
in a system or in the future
via the action of an adversary,
but they're degrading the
usability of that system
in some fundamental way.
We want this process to happen
as rapidly and effectively
as possible--
right time, right
data, right analyst.
And what we face
today is not just
database access, insider
threat, SQL injection,
all these other things.
It is the compilation
of the interaction
of these forces within
a situation of extremely
high uncertainty.
If anybody's ever
remediated a security
or a technical incident
of extreme complexity,
you know that when the
incident first starts,
you can even be sure
of what you know.
And what we're demonstrating
with this pipeline is
that we are removing-- we
are systematically removing
uncertainty from these
decisions for our consumers,
our consumers being the
security operation center
professionals that 24/7,
365 defend the city
from cyber threats
and the network
and IT operations
professionals which run
those systems every single day.
So as a extension
of that metaphor,
we need to systematically
apply insight.
People, the term
machine learning,
and advanced automation,
people don't actually
want machine learning.
They want learning.
They don't want
advanced automation.
They want the right thing
done as fast as possible.
So what our platform
enables is those workflows
to be systematically understood,
to be programmatically applied,
and to be repeated at scale.
And like all organizations
like all projects of this scale
and complexity, there's
a number of challenges.
One is the scale volume and
federation as I intimated.
The city is an organization of--
it has over 330,000
employees, as I
said 400,000 end points, a total
of about a million systems.
There's hundreds
agencies ranging
from the absolutely incredible
public safety professionals
of the NYPD and FDNY patrolling
the streets every single day
to the mayor's office of
Immigrant Affairs doing
absolutely critical cutting
edge work in support
of at risk communities,
50,000 police officers, much
much, much less than that,
immigration and civil service
professionals.
So that scale volume
and federation
makes it a very large
complex organization.
Two, as I mentioned, the threat
surface and attack surface
is growing.
Three, I mentioned why
platform approaches
for some-- for an organization
like ours are not sufficient.
And while they might
be sufficient for some,
an entity of our size
and sophistication
is never going to be satisfied
with a single vendor.
And number 4 is technical debt.
The city has been doing
computers since the mid 60s.
The city has been
offering services
to residents, visitors,
and businesses
with mainframes since the
days of the IBM System/360.
So this is an organization which
has a long and storied history
of using computing to
further the public good,
and that means that we
must approach our legacy
systems with data,
not wishful thinking.
Again how do we deal with
more data, more formats,
and more locations?
More formats and
more data obviously,
I talked about all
these systems I
mentioned throw of
data, large and small.
More formats, it's not just a
sys log feed over UDP anymore.
We have API-based access.
We have platform and software
as a service offerings
that the city uses.
And more locations, the city
has a hybrid cloud strategy
like many organizations,
so it's not just
on premise data centers.
It's not just one
public cloud provider.
It's all of the above.
So with all that
really as background,
our approach for security
data is, one, cloud native.
We are built primarily on
Apache Beam and open source data
programming model and
the TLDR of Apache Beam,
it is highly parallel--
so it's fast--
and you can apply the
same data transformations
both on batch and in stream.
And what that means is for
a small dedicated growing
organization like ourselves,
we can spend more time
understating our data and
transforming it in a way
that our consumers refine--
will find meaningful than on
either running infrastructure
because we leverage Cloud
Dataflow from Google
than on the deep technical
underpinnings of a data
management model itself.
Two is zero trust, zero touch.
We believe that the
BeyondCorp architecture,
obviously spearheaded by
Google and now embraced
by others in the BeyondCorp
alliance announced yesterday,
is the architecture
of the future.
Briefly, BeyondCorp
for zero trust
is removing authorization
and access decisions
from single points and
making them compilations
of decisions either about
what you know about a user,
what you know about a system, or
some combination of the above.
And zero touch, utilizing
infrastructure as code,
enables us to scale rapidly
elastically and apply
best practices.
And we're not just
security professionals.
We're also evangelists,
so this is an opportunity
through this project to eat
our own dog food with regards
to BeyondCorp and
zero touch that we
can bring to city agencies
along with the security
outcomes we deliver
to our stakeholders.
Number 3, modularity.
It's a flexible architecture.
One of the key
differentiators is
that this is a publish and
subscribe architecture rather
than a request and response.
So that means we can take things
out and add them very rapidly.
The fact that we combine
this with infrastructure
as code increases our
velocity and our reliability
so that's all--
those are things that
are worth focusing on.
And it's fast.
We intentionally
built this to be fast.
And I think the next
slide I actually
have some of the metrics.
Because if it is fast, you can
apply advanced things later.
But if it starts out
and it's not fast,
it's very hard to
make it fast later.
So we built it
with speed in mind.
Obviously we use
the best technology,
the right open source projects,
the right architecture,
and we'll talk
about why that is.
But we believe that to be-- this
is a machine speed problem, not
a human speed problem.
So we want to counter our
latency in milliseconds and not
seconds.
How many milliseconds?
So we on the average day
process billions and billions
of events.
Actually yesterday I think
we processed slightly
over 12 billion events.
And with-- the
average processing
time is less than
10 milliseconds.
That's to do-- over the
next couple of slides,
I'll show you all of the things
we're doing in less than 10
milliseconds.
And like I said, speed
has a quality all its own
because you can deliver
insights faster,
you can apply later
transformations
at incredible scale, you
can do things in sequence
that if you start out year
over some several seconds,
it's very hard to make
things fast later.
How fast is 10 milliseconds?
It's about 50 times faster
than you blink your eye,
and it's about--
if anybody remembers what
analog cameras looked like--
a 1/60th shutter is
about 10 milliseconds.
So pretty fast.
So I want to spend just
a couple of minutes
on our high-level diagram,
and before I start this,
we are in the process of writing
a white paper and open sourcing
many of not just the
architecture but the code
we use to do this.
So obviously feel free to
take a picture of your phone,
but over the summer we're
going to be open sourcing
this somewhere to follow.
And we view this as the
start of a discussion,
not the end of a discussion.
And for those of you that have
seen some of these other booths
outside, you'll recognize
a lot of these tools.
I want to start with number one,
orienting you to my diagram.
On the lower left, we
have an abstraction
for our on premise data centers,
so I'm going to start there.
Starting for the lower left
where that 1 just appeared,
we have log collectors
and multiple data centers.
We scale them horizontally.
We have internal load balancing.
And additionally we apply
BeyondCorp principles.
These are denied
by default. These
are controlled by programmatic
regular key rotation
via service account.
They communicate only
via two-way SSL 443
over the internet.
They're accessible via
a fully qualified domain
name internally and
externally, things like this.
And additionally
we apply metadata.
One of the key things about
a published and subscribe
framework like this is you--
thou shalt apply metadata.
We apply metadata about as
many things as we can think of.
And we also have
a framework that
allows us to change
the kinds of metadata
that we apply without
fundamentally re-architecting
our system or taking the
system offline to do that.
That's because we have this
load balance configuration,
and some of the SRE
principles you probably
heard about in the
Five Nines Lounge,
we apply throughout
this pipeline.
And, two, we have what we
call cloud-to-cloud data.
As I said, the city has
a hybrid cloud strategy.
So we via API and
service accounts
using the same
BeyondCorp principles,
key rotation, et cetera,
extract that data via API
from multiple public cloud
providers including Google,
including others.
And that's because we want
to leverage the investments
that the city has
made in these clouds
to provide cutting edge
services to residents
and introduce them
into our pipeline.
And number 3, the middle
part of the slide, we
have a ingestion front end.
It's a Pub/Sub.
As you might have--
you could probably
guess, it uses
a topic in subscription schema.
This topic in
subscription schema
is one that is primarily
used later in our pipeline
to parse and prepare
logs for consumers,
which I'll get to in a second.
And so there's a front end.
We call that ingest right
where to the left of the three,
and what it does
is it takes in data
from all of these places
from our data centers
from our other public
cloud providers.
And it adds it to
the right topic.
It applies a little
bit more metadata.
And it passes it off to
something we call flow control.
Flow control is an
Apache Beam pipeline,
which ensures that the data
is in the right format,
that the data is
expected, and really it's
a place that we can
apply metadata level
automation and normalization
across this data without--
in nerd speak--
deserializing these packets.
And that's like I said
because we want it to be fast
because we want
and because we do
use multiple
concurrent topics, we
want to be able to serve the
data as fast as our fastest
consumer wants to consume it
rather than be limited by as
slow as our slowest process.
So to do that,
that is why we have
to Apache Beam subscriptions
if you will instead of one
like some of the other pipelines
you might see around the hall.
I also want to
point your attention
to the-- there's a blue
box which is our primary,
and there's also a gray
box which is replica.
And so we have--
we rely on Google managed
services, which provide
a high level of reliability.
But we via our infrastructure
as code and other processes
replicate this pipeline to
other geographic locations,
and that's to ensure continuity
and disaster recovery.
And we don't, quote, operate
two separate infrastructures
via infrastructure as code.
We simply tell Google put
this over there as well,
and I'll get into that also.
And number 4, we have
another Apache Beam pipeline
which parses data.
And broadly speaking,
our consumers
want a variety of things.
I mean consumers, I mean
analytical processes and tools.
Some analytical
processes and tools
want data to be normalized.
They just want you
to make sure it's--
they just want a well-formatted
JSON message and they're happy.
Some of them want the
data to be fully indexed.
They want it to be transformed
into a CSV or an [? AVRO ?]
or another type of message
which has a high structure.
Others want the data
to be fully digitized.
So you might imagine
that those are--
some of those are relatively
straightforward to do
and some of those are not.
Because we use this publish
and subscribe framework
because we have these
two message buses,
these two Pub/Sub
sandwiches, if you will
we can do that like I said and
serve our fastest customer now
and our, quote, slowest
customer at their own speed.
And that is, I think,
a key differentiator
with our architecture,
and, like I said,
that enables us to be
fast and stay fast.
Number 5, we call
this the replicator.
We have a production and
development environment.
And importantly about our
development environment
is it's only there
when we want it.
Obviously we're civil servants.
These are taxpayer resources.
In addition to
effectiveness, we need
to be ruthlessly efficient.
So we don't have a separate
development environment
which is, quote, sitting
around waiting us for to--
waiting for us to develop.
Via infrastructure
as code, we stand up
a development environment.
We want to push major changes.
We want to do ATT&CK
framework testing.
Will we want to
test integrations
and other services,
things like this,
and we do that via
the replicator.
We have a variety of
projects ongoing at any one
time, a variety of
stakeholders, which
want what we might call
R&D or non-production level
access to our data.
And this replicator enables
us to take some, all,
or some subset of our production
data, put it to these,
apply masking, apply
tokenization and other
processes without affecting
these downstream consumers.
And that allows us
to continue to apply
best practices BeyondCorp
type principles
throughout this
production pipeline.
Moving right along, these are
just some of the consumers--
automation orchestration,
dashboard and alerting,
data warehouse--
I'm actually going
to-- during the demo
I'll show you BigQuery, which
we use for our data warehouse.
But this is like I said just
one small part of a very
large production system.
Number 7, if you see is--
in the middle top,
infrastructure as code
means that your
operators write software.
Software requires CICD, code
repos, and artifact storage.
So we have that.
There's no secret.
It's people writing software,
and like anything, it
requires maybe a
change of perspective
or a change in the way your
operational teams might
think of themselves.
But we found that the engineers
and operators on our team
have really embraced
this challenge,
so I think that it is a journey
that certainly doesn't happen
overnight but one
that we've been
found to be very successful.
And last, but
certainly not least,
is we use the Identity Aware
Proxy to broker access from
users to all of our production
applications that means that we
have context to our
access with user identity,
with device date,
with other things .
And again this enables us to
get right data, right analysts,
right now.
So with that, demo.
Can we switch the display?
Great.
So here we have a number of
virtual missing instances.
Actually this one is the booth
demo, so I won't shut this down
or Andrew would be very
sad and I'd be very sad.
So this is the booth demo.
You see dataflow is just virtual
machines, so there's no secret.
Again, there's no secrets here.
It's just virtual
machines running Java.
But now I'll go
to this live demo.
And this is actually
the same code
that's in the demo
outside, but instead
of those awesome
buttons that you press,
for those of you
that have seen it,
I'm just going to press
buttons on a keyboard.
Just give it a seconds just
to go to space and back.
Great.
So this is again the
same button demo.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to publish a malicious message.
So I published a
malicious SSH log,
and the last four digits
of the message ID are 9816.
So remember those numbers.
It'll there's a test later.
And so these are all
the dataflow jobs,
and there's two ways
you can view this.
One, here all our dataflow jobs.
Two, here all the
machines that are
running those dataflow jobs.
But you see they are things
like third party, SSH, DNS,
so these are dataflow jobs
that are subscribing to our hub
subtopics, applying
transformation,
and auto magically giving it to
another Pub/Sub topic, which is
then writing it the BigQuery.
So that's at a high
level what's going on.
And as we move over
to BigQuery in a sec,
imagine not just
me on the console
and BigQuery applying
these SQL queries.
Imagine this were a unified
framework with an automation
and orchestration harness
where these queries could
be run automatically
via the BigQuery API.
These transformations could be
applied and rerun many times
a day in parallel
and in sequence.
Automation could be kicked
off both in this environment
and within other
stakeholders environments.
So this is a
trivial demo to show
you the power of a
framework like this.
Additionally, because we're
using BigQuery and Google
Tools like this, our
analysts actually mostly
don't use the BigQuery UI.
Most of them use Jupyter
notebooks, iPython notebooks
and things like
that to prototype
within our development
environment, which we then
normal software
development process promote
to production via our automation
orchestration framework.
So all of this is preamble
to maybe first we'll just--
and this is just SQL.
Again nothing earth shattering,
just select from our demo,
and make sure that
our message is there.
You have to take my word for
it, but it is the same message.
And you see so time, source IP,
source board, destination IP,
right failure.
So this, for example, could be
a malicious actor attempting
to SSH into a host that was
within our on premise data
center.
So let's say-- let's
take that as the example.
And again this
would probably not
be in the context
of a BigQuery UI.
It has to be in the context
of an alerting dashboard
and a response process.
So obviously let's take
a look at this address,
the destination IP.
So we receive an
alert about someone
trying to do something
bad to our hosts.
Now let's see what else is
happening to this host briefly.
So now we're just saying gimme
all the SSH logs from our host.
So we see a bunch of
failures and undetermined,
which is a different kind
of failure in SSH logs,
undetermined.
We see a success.
And I actually see a
lot a bunch of failures
within the recent time frame.
So this is 308, 302.
So these are all temporally
relatively recent failure.
Success doesn't matter,
undetermined interesting.
So let's say there's this
110 address, which we
see a bunch of failures from.
So now we have understood.
We received an alert.
Someone's trying to
SSH into this system.
We look back-- let's
call it 10 minutes--
and we see a bunch
of other failures
not from this initial system
but from other systems trying
to access the same system.
So this could be a
brute force SSH attempt.
That's so this could be.
Now let's just filter
by this 110 address
and maybe see if we can
see anything else going on.
Now all 22, 22, 22, failure.
They're all failures.
So now I'm more convinced still
that this is a brute force SSH
attempt.
Now let's see-- we have
just the SSH logs here.
Let's pivot from SSH to
all the logs that we have.
Now for the purposes of
this demo, we have DNS,
SSH, web server, logs,
but in, quote, real life,
you might have a number
of different log sources
that would depend on how your
use cases and your threat
management team or whatever
your processes are developed.
But for the purposes of
this demo, it's just a few.
So we see more of these poor 22.
Now we see a bunch of DNS.
So we see 53 mail dot Google.
So we see a bunch of
other things going on.
And at this point, this might
be the point at which this was
delivered to a human analyst.
Everything up to now
could have been--
you could-- you don't
have to necessarily
have a person do it.
It's-- to prototype, you would
obviously have to design these
queries, implement thresholds,
production, unit testing,
smoke testing, again, no secrets
about how these processes would
have to be undertaken.
But let's say brute forcing
SSH against a jump server
were one of your use
cases, this might
be the kind of contextual,
quote, advanced automation
you could do with a
pipeline like this.
So a lot of the NSS--
in SSH so let's
see other than this
if they tried to connect
to anything else.
So now I'm-- maybe
I'm a human analyst.
I'm in my iPython
notebook, I'm sitting,
and I say I have my source IP.
I already know there's
a bunch of DNS and SSH,
so I'm done looking at DNS and
SSH so let's look at the stuff.
So now they have tried to
connect to something else.
And this is a brand new system.
I didn't know about
this system before.
It wasn't organic to
my alert, but I've
pivoted from a brute force--
an SSH alert that
was decorated that
was enriched by our pipeline and
data within our data warehouse.
I then served that
to an analyst, who
then applied human machine
learning-- human thinking
and said, I'm interested
in this alert.
Let's see if they try to
connect to anything else.
And now I could do this
whole process again
with this new indicator-- a
potential indicator of attack.
And again I wouldn't
necessarily have
to run all these queries again.
I could simply feed this
back into the system,
wait a couple milliseconds for
another decorated contextual
data element to appear to me as
a human analyst, and on we go.
So that's the end of that demo
and now back to the slides.
If you could switch
back to the other one.
Great.
So zero trust and zero touch,
I have just a couple of minutes
before I want to leave
some time for questions.
And zero touch
infrastructure as code
and how do we deploy systems
today as an organization?
Obviously the city is a
hybrid cloud provider.
It has, like I
said, a long history
of computing excellence.
Physical data centers
are here to say.
Data gravity is an
important consideration
in how applications are
designed and architected.
We're dedicated to ensuring
that those systems are also
secure and reliable.
But like I said, we wanted
to implement a fully
infrastructure as code, a
fully zero touch application.
And that means that we had
to transition or enhance
our operational processes from
those of pure IT operations
to development operations,
DevOps, and SRE principles.
That means that we
have peer review,
all codes are pushed to
a central repo, reviewed
by a select group,
audit abilities, 100%,
and our controls are
technically enforced.
So we have obviously
robust policy documents
which delineate who can
make changes to what.
But don't just take
my word for it.
We segment our environment
by project, by repository.
And using Terraform and
open source CI/CD tools,
we can technically
enforce our policies.
And again, one of the principles
that I saw and I read--
I responded to is we
don't want to blame people
when something fails.
We want to blame the system.
So we wanted to construct
a system to allow people,
knowing that they are
fallible, to receive
the maximum technical
enforcement of our already
agreed upon principles as
an engineering culture.
And that means that--
and some of those things started
with infrastructure as code,
but they go to
good peer reviews.
They go to lunch and learns.
They go to a robust blameless
post-mortem culture.
And if you don't
have these principles
and you don't technically
enforce these tools, at least
in our experience, it's easy
to enhance a system in which it
is accepted that people are
human beings and fallible
and that we seek to
technically enforce things
that we all agree on
rather than saying
you should be more careful.
And infrastructure as code
again, there's no secrets.
This is actually part of
the code that runs the demo.
And you see that these are,
if any of you use Kafka--
if you haven't
used Cloud Pub/Sub
and you have used Kafka,
these look like Kafka topics
because these are Cloud
Pub/Sub subtopics,
and that's basically
what they are.
So we adjust third party.
We do things flow control.
So again secret is
there's no secret.
And again, because we're
using infrastructure
as code because we have
in the documentation,
we might say that--
if I were reviewing Andrew's
code, I'd say I would--
I want more documentation
on your code.
It's not really clear to me
what these variables are.
Well, let's pretend that
as part of our code review,
we can ensure that our
infrastructure as code
is well documented
because we're not
at some different
point in time taking
some snapshot of our environment
and then documenting it.
This is the documentation
of our environment right
here, the
infrastructure as code.
And like I said, we have a
full development and testing
environment.
We have geographically
redundant components
for critical systems,
and we don't do that
by clicking a bunch of buttons.
We do that by introducing
variables into our Terraform
code-- which is what this is.
This is HCL-- and having
the computer do it for us.
And zero trust--
and for those of you
that haven't heard
about BeyondCorp
or haven't read the white
papers from Forrester Research
or by Google themselves
and BeyondCorp,
we remove the trust
in the network
and place it in what we know
about the user, the device,
and the context.
Our pipeline uses
these principles
again throughout the pipeline to
ensure that our environment is
secure and because
we believe that this
is the future way
that applications
will be architected.
And again this is going
to happen overnight.
The city has been a city
actually about 120 years longer
than the United States of
America has been a country.
So the city as an
organization is
one with a rich
history of transition
and using inflection points.
And we're confident
that the city is going
to move in this direction.
And we're excited to
be a very small part
of that team of teams like I
said that's going to do it.
But you have to start someplace.
And for those in the audience,
I want to do infrastructure
as code, I want
to try BeyondCorp,
this is a big,
important application.
But it's one in
which we deliberately
selected to apply both
of these principles
not just because we believe
in those principles,
we think that the future, and
we think they're important,
but this was small enough to be
accomplishable but big enough
to matter.
And I think selecting the
kind of problem or project
you as an organization
apply these cutting edge
next generation or whatever
you want to call it
principles for is important.
And moving right along
as another way of analogy
because "Game of
Thrones" is restarting,
we wanted to put a
picture of a castle in.
And so the analogy is simple.
We have a castle.
We have old, we have legacy,
we have all these systems,
and we need to do
two things at once.
We need to chew
bubblegum and walk.
We need to embrace next
generation technologies
and novel approaches
to solving problems
while ensuring that our existing
systems are robust and secure.
And since the adoption
of the internet,
many organizations have tried
and succeeded in doing this,
and we think that
our organization
with the help of Google
and other partners
is going to succeed as well
and that your organization
hopefully can, too.
And the future, just a couple
of minutes, machine learning
and advanced automation.
Like I said at the
beginning, people
don't want machine learning.
They want learning, and they
don't want advanced automation.
They want the thing they want
done to be done really fast.
So a data centric,
automation focused approach
like that you saw
here enables that.
And centaur chests, what we're--
our vision for
what we want to do
isn't to hire a bunch of robots
to replace a bunch of people.
That's never going to happen.
What we want to do--
and if you've never
heard of centaur chests,
it's a person un-personed
or a person machine team
a computer applies the
strategy and tactics
of its human operator.
So using a person to think
strategically to draw analogy
to make plans and designs
and then having a system
execute those at high
velocity, high reliability,
and high scale.
That's what we're trying to do.
Training-- machine learning pun
intended-- people and machines
to work together.
And last but not
least, key takeaways.
One, the benefit of using the
public cloud for this purpose--
scalability, performance,
efficiency, and the ability
to technology leapfrog.
We selected a brand new
application that was important,
executive sponsorship,
big impact,
and we sought to apply
these principles on purpose.
Two, our approach zero trust,
zero touch, and the power
of data, which broadly
speaking one of the primary--
the first things we did was
robust retrospective search
but that's just the beginning.
And number 3, enable the
future today with automation,
machine learning, published
and subscribed frameworks.
And number 4, not on the slide,
white paper coming this summer,
hopefully we start a
conversation with all of you.
Follow us on Twitter, New
York City Cyber Command.
Questions about any of this, we
have a contact email up there.
And for any information
about our office, about us,
about what we do, about our
programs, nyc.gov/cyber.
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]